ich habe letztens eine Geschichte gehört
wie jemand nach 6 Jahren sein
Sparschwein geschlachtet hat und da
waren einfach 12000 € nur in Münzen drin
so ein sparschwean ist schon was geiles
aber nachdem wir mit dem Smart
klorollenhalter der die Rolle immer
automatisch richtig rumdreht bereits die
Industrie revolutioniert haben schauen
wir jetzt wie man ein gutes altes
Sparschwein durch moderne Technik noch
geiler machen kann und damit auch noch
mehr Geld beiseite legen kann alles
beginnt mit dem Konzept meiner Meinung
nach ist das größte Problem an normalen
Sparschwein dass man nicht sieht wie
viel Geld drin ist und um das zu beheben
braucht ein geldzählmechanismus jetzt
haben wir überegt man dafür einfach ein
für 20 € aus dem Internet kauft aber ich
dachte wir bauen den Mechanismus einfach
selber weil wir scheinbar sonst n besser
zu tun haben und weil es geiler ist wir
müssen also jede Münze zählen dafür
müssen die allerdings erstmal sortiert
werden damit wir auch wissen okay wie
viel Wert hat die einzelne Münze und
dafür brauchst ein sortiermechanismus
und so ein haben wir auch eigentlich
überall im Internet gefunden z.B hier es
mega krass wie simpel dieses Konzept ist
und wie gut das halt auch scheinbar
funktioniert und weil ich das auch ger
mal selber probieren will haben wir
sowas in 3D gedruckt also das ist das
einfache Ding hier das hier ausreichen
soll Münzen sortieren das Pack ich jetzt
nicht so richtig Euro habe ich nicht
jetzt gib direkt 50 Cent okay da fällt
aber auch beim Euro
raus oder vielleicht ist der Euro auch
kleiner als 50 Cent und fällt vorher
raus oha ach so läuft das nämlich also 2
€ fallen ganz unten raus die 50 Cent
fallen im vorletzten raus und der Euro
fällt dann im dritten raus und ist
einfach ja gut ist kleiner als 50 Cent
warum eigentlich macht ja gar keinen
Sinn okay 20 Cent üerspringen verrauen
wir auch mal aber 10 Cent fällt hier
raus nee 10 Cent sollten da nicht
rausfallen oder 50 Cent 1 € 20 Cent und
eigentlich soll 10 cusen kann das sein
ach gleiche Trick ich Fall wieder ich
fall jedes mal drauf rein ne Beil 5 Cent
der größer sind als 10 Cent warum das
macht gar keinen Sinn aus gedacht das
ist übel cool das einfach alles so weit
durchrutscht bis es da
reinfällt ja am Ende ist sortiert jetzt
wo der Plan für den Mechanismus im
Inneren steht geht's ans Design wir
werden das Sparschwein dafür im Stil vom
Warp Sparschwein Konti aus honkai
starrail bauen dem sponsser des heutigen
Videos das sieht mega futuristisch aus
und ist deswegen perfekt für unser Smart
Sparschwein jetzt haben wir aber das
Problem dass das hier echt riesig ist
und nicht so wirklich ins Schwein glaube
ich reinpasst und meiner Meinung nach
soll so ein Sparschwein schon bisschen
kleiner sein als ein echtes Schwein also
müssen wir uns da noch was einfahen
lassen dafür wir haben jetzt überlegt
und wollten schon fast zwei Schlitze ins
Schwein reinmachen das Teil hier
halbieren und dann halt ne die die
halben Bahn dafür nehmen eine Bahn für
die großen Münzen und eine Bahn für die
kleinen Münzen aber das wäre natürlich
ein bisschen dumm wenn man sie selber
sortiert dann kann man sie auch
eigentlich fast selber zählen drum muss
andere Lösung her die Lösung des Problem
war es dann einfach noch eine Kurve in
den sortiermechanismus einzubauen die
die Münzen einmal in die andere Richtung
umlenkt und schon hat der Mechanismus
einen deutlich kleineren Fußabdruck und
das Sparschwein muss nicht Originalgröße
haben also ST mal ganz simpel ja mit 2
Cent die fallen da raus ne 5 Cent fällt
auch dar raus rausfahren soll 10 Cent
auch ein bra gar nicht testen spannend
wird jetzt mit den da
unten das ist so
krass ich find Mechanismus also ohne
Witz ich find zu geil ich fin viel
geiler als man den finden sollte weil
der ist schon echt simpel der
sortiermechanismus hier passt als
nächstes machen wir das eigentliche
Sparschwein dafür haben wir uns ein 3D
Modell vom wschwein organisiert leicht
angepasst und in unseren 3D Drucker
geschmissen das hier ist eine timelapse
von der unteren Hälfte die bestimmt
wieder mal mega geil ausgesehen hätte
wenn das Licht gewesen wä mal schauen
wie der Druck aussehen wird in Action
erleben könnt ihr das W sparsin konte
übrigens in honkai starrail das ist ein
Weltraum Fantasy RPG von den Machern von
genchen impact dass ihr auf dem PC auf
eurem Handy und jetzt auch auf der PS5
kostenlos spielen können und der
Spielfortschritt wird zwischen allen
Geräten synchronisiert ihr erkundet in
hongkai staray die verschiedenen Welten
des riesigen Universums löst knifflige
Rätsel und besiegt Feinde in taktischen
Kämpfen jeder der über 20 einzigartigen
Helden mit denen ihr euer Team selbst
zusammenstellen könnt hat seine eigene
spannende backstory im neuen Update 1.4
erwartet euch nicht nur eine komplett
neue Story sondern es kommen zwei neue
zeitlich begrenzte fünf sternehelden
dazu die legendäre
eiszerstörungsschwertkämpferin die sich
im Kampf transformieren kann jingliu und
Topas die feuerjagdheldin die im Kampf
ihren Begleiter beschwört und zwar unser
war sparin Konti wenn ihr das Spiel an
sieben Tagen in Folge startet bekommt
ihr Zeh specialpäe mit denen ihr die
Chance habt diese neuen Helden
freizuschalten ladet euch das Spiel über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung runter
so der 3D Druck ist fertig so kam der
raus super geil geworden krass dass man
so eine crazy Form einfach aus so einer
Rolle entstehen lassen kann und jetzt
steht's hier ah ist auf jeden Fall schon
prächtig super cool geworden da muss der
Mechanismus jetzt rein und der passt da
auch rein irgendwie so da kommt noch die
zweite Hälfte drüber das ist jetzt
erstmal die untere Hälfte müns Ruts rein
und fällt einfach genau da raus wo sie
raus soll aber ja wieso sortieren wir
jetzt einfach das Geld am Ende liegt
auch trotzdem alles im gleichen Behälter
drin das stimmt aber wir wollen das Geld
ja zählen der Plan ist folgender die
Münzen fallen perfekt ztiert durch den
Mechanismus jetzt können wir unter jedes
Loch eine Lichtschranke machen die
registriert wenn eine Münze durchfällt
so sehen die Teile nämlich aus
und die funktionieren so auf der einen
Seite ist eine LED auf der anderen Seite
ist ein Lichtsensor und sobald jetzt
hier so eine Münze durchfällt blockiert
die das Licht der Lichtsensor kriegt
kein Licht mehr und das Ding löst aus
und dadurch kann ich jede einzelne Münze
zählen die in der sparschwin eingeworfen
wird und wenn ich die alle am Ende adere
K ich raus wie Geld insgesamten sparch
eingeworfen wurde ganz
[Applaus]
einfach
und damit wir diese Lichtschranken auch
jeweils unter die münzlöcher befestigen
können haben wir diesen
sortiermechanismus noch um so Schächte
ergänzt in denen die Münzen dann auch
gut geführt durch die jeweiligen
Lichtschranken fallen können die
wiederum daran auch befestigt werden ihr
seht jetzt gerade das Display steh 0,00
€ drauf jetzt t wir mal das alles so
funktioniert wie wir uns erhoffen ich
Hal das mal so hin 2 € rein
ja zack EUR ja wird geupdatet 50 Cent
rein
2,52 254 ist krass wie zuverlässig das
funktioniert
8,4 854 geiler Mechanismus und der muss
jetzt irgendwie ins Schwein während die
obere Hälfte von unserem Sparschwein
gedruckt wurde ist einfach das weiße
filament leer geworden aber unser neuer
3D Drucker erkennt das von selbst und
schiebt automatisch eine neue Rolle an
filament hinterher und druckt dann
weiter also in der Theorie zumindest das
neue filament war einfach so schlecht
auf die Spule gewickelt dass die sich
einfach nicht von selbst abwickeln
konnte zum Glück hat Manu diese
mittelschwere Katastrophe bemerkt und
der neuen Rolle ein bisschen Starthilfe
gegeben jetzt sollte das Teil fertig
drucken können das heißt wir haben jetzt
hier den Unterbau vom Schwein und jetzt
hier quasi das was oben drauf kommt ma
ich jetzt mal hier kurz von der Print
plate
ab so das ist echt krass geworden wir
bemalen später aber noch komen nämlich
noch goldene Elemente ran J aber das ist
das Schwein nächste Challenge ist das
alles hier Reinz kriegen hier gibt's
übrigens reset button ja aktuell sind
wir hier bei 11,8 zack wieder auf Null
und dann geht's V vorne los irw ausleht
ja okay also offensichtlich ist das
jetzt einfach zu groß geworden
trotzdemchanismus das ist bisschen blöd
aber ich habe eine Idee wir das ein
bisschen kleiner machen können das ist
jetzt allerdings bchen Freestyle aber
ich glaube ich habe eine gute
Idee jetzt habe ich das so ein Stück
rausgeschnitten das man hoffentlich
nicht braucht und jetzt klebe ich noch
mal neu
dran das und das Zwischenstück habe ich
jetzt also rausgeworfen dadurch wurde
das Ganze etwas kürzer und hat jetzt
reingepasst ist drin funktioniert das
Display das wir vorhin schon gesehen
haben ist hier oben jetzt auch eingebaut
und damit passt der Deckel jetzt hier
drauf und da schauen mal
münzewerf zack ein Cent okay ich zeig
das mal von Namen komm warum okay hier
haben wir jetzt gerade ein Cent ma 50
Cent rein und 51 Cent das funktioniert€
50 Cent noch mal 50
Cent 20 Cent ja und so sparen man sich
Geld und weiß auch genau wie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viel
faststunde ja und das Schwein bemalen
wir jetzt auch
noch mit wir me ich so wie mal nach
zahlen kannst mir noch zahlen drauf
malen damit ich weiß wo ich welche Farbe
h muss
nee kann nämlich nicht
schreiben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt angemalt aus das
Geldzählen funktioniert natürlich immer
noch mega satisfine ich ma mal so ein
bisschen Sorgen ob diese Anzeige jetzt
auch tatsächlich 12000 € überhaupt
anzeigen könnte aber ich glaube wenn es
soweit ist ist mir das auch egal
probiert jetzt das Spiel honkeai staray
gerne mal aus mit dem Code in der
Infobox bekommt ihr da übrigens 60
stellare Jade mit denen ihr die neuen
Helden bekommen könnt also klickt auf
den Link in der Videobeschreibung und
Spiel eine Runde und damit war von
diesem Video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen macht's gut ciao